Trascrizione: Alessia Giorgiutti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Provate a pensare alla vostra infanzia.
Chi ha avuto la fortuna
di correre a piedi nudi su un prato?
[Un dono per tutta la vita]
Chi si ricorda com'era lasciare per primo
le impronte sulla neve fresca?
Chi è stato tra i privilegiati
a tornare a casa
con le mani o i piedi sporchi di fango,
o appiccicati di pece?
E com'era?
Era così bello da poter dire
"indimenticabile",
se ce lo ricordiamo
a tutti questi anni di distanza.
Ecco perché abbiamo il dovere
di trasmettere questo dono
ai nostri figli, ai nostri nipoti,
alle persone che conosciamo.
Noi, che abbiamo avuto la fortuna
di avere questo rapporto
così stretto con la natura -
un rapporto vero, non costruito:
la natura l'abbiamo sperimentata
in prima persona,
non l'abbiamo studiata sui libri e basta -
non possiamo sottrarci al compito
di offrire ai nostri figli
la possibilità di sperimentare
lo stesso contatto diretto.
È un dovere che abbiamo
nei loro confronti.
Ognuno di noi ha dei valori importanti
che pensa di dover tramandare,
o dover trasmettere,
alle persone che ci stanno intorno.
Per me, la natura è uno di questi.
Tutto è cambiato quando, poi,
sono diventata mamma.
Avevo un pancione grande così,
e avevo un nonno
che mi riempiva di attenzioni:
anche lui amante della montagna,
ma mi diceva:
"Non vorrai mica andare
in cima a una montagna,
con quel pancione così?
È pericoloso!
E la mia nipotina,
sballottata lì dentro?".
Ma come, mi chiedevo: una donna incinta
non deve perseguire prima di tutto
il proprio benessere fisico e psichico?
E se il mio benessere
è in cima a una montagna,
perché devo smettere di andare
a camminare in montagna?
C'è poi chi faceva proprio del terrorismo.
Mi dicevano:
"Ah, quando nascerà la bambina, abituati,
non andrai più a camminare.
Gli scarponi puoi metterli
già in cantina".
Per fortuna, sulla mia strada
ho incontrato altre persone
che erano delle voci
un po' fuori dal coro, come me.
Tra queste, Francesca Tosolini,
che è qui tra il pubblico,
e Sara Baroselli, che virtualmente
è qui vicino a me.
Con loro abbiamo avuto la possibilità
di condividere un'idea, un'esperienza,
che poi ha dato vita
ad una pagina Facebook
attraverso la quale suggeriamo
diversi itinerari a misura di bambino
nel nostro Friuli.
Quindi, dicevamo, le attese:
"Che cosa succederà
quando diventerò mamma?
Continuerò a camminare?"
Mi sono detta:
"Inutile farsi troppe domande:
aspettiamo e vediamo che cosa succederà".
Ebbene, l'istinto materno -
che difficilmente sbaglia -
e per fortuna anche tanti pediatri
lo dicono da subito:
i bambini, quando sono sani
e quando il parto è stato regolare,
devono stare all'aperto da subito,
indipendentemente dalla stagione:
perché se in primavera
è facile portarli fuori,
in inverno bisogna essere
un po' più coraggiosi.
Eppure c'è una teoria,
che si chiama "Ariaterapia",
attraverso la quale si sottolinea
come i bambini che stanno
più ore all'aperto
paradossalmente si ammalino di meno,
perché i germi e virus circolano
negli spazi chiusi e riscaldati.
Quindi, all'aperto da subito.
Per il bene del bambino, ma non solo:
anche per il bene della mamma!
Perché stare all'aperto,
a contatto con la natura,
permette - lo dicono
diversi studi scientifici -
di ridurre il "baby blues",
quella depressione
che colpisce tante mamme
vittime un po' di solitudine,
un po' di sbalzi ormonali.
E quindi, cosa c'è di meglio
che fare una passeggiata in natura,
possibilmente in compagnia
di qualche amica positiva?
E il nostro Friuli è pieno zeppo
di passeggiate che si adattano
a queste esigenze.
Basta allontanarsi
pochi chilometri da qua:
ci sono il Parco del Cormôr,
il Parco del Beato Bertrando,
oppure il Parco delle Risorgive,
a Codroipo,
e per chi ama il mare
c'è il Sentiero Rilke,
che è una poesia tra passeggiata e mare.
Tutto questo, tra l'altro,
ha dei benefici non da poco
nello sviluppo del bambino,
perché [se i bambini crescono così],
sono tantissimi gli stimoli
che possono ricevere.
Finché stanno distesi nel passeggino
vedono le ombre,
vedono le foglie in lontananza;
poi stanno seduti,
e quindi possono iniziare a guardare
da una posizione privilegiata.
E poi i primi passi:
primi passi sulle erbe,
primi passi sulla sabbia.
È veramente un trionfo
di sensi, la natura.
Si possono osservare
le foglie che si muovono,
i piccoli insetti.
Si possono assaggiare
i doni preziosi del bosco:
i frutti di bosco, le fragole.
Poi, per i bambini un po' più grandi,
raccoglierli è veramente un dono
che vale più di qualunque medaglia.
Si può usare il tatto
per sentire le diverse consistenze:
i ricci delle castagne pungono,
ma la castagna invece è liscia.
E si può usare l'udito
per sentire il rumore delle foglie,
ma anche per sentire
il canto degli uccellini.
Ed è un tempo prezioso
per usare la voce a basso volume,
per poter usare benissimo
tutti quanti i sensi.
Da questo, è nata
la nostra pagina Facebook,
"Camminare coi bambini
in Friuli e dintorni".
Era il giugno del 2015
quando con Francesca, Sara e altre mamme
abbiamo deciso di dare vita
a questa pagina
che, in un batter d'occhio, ha avuto
un successo incredibile per noi.
Non ce lo immaginavamo:
volevamo, semplicemente,
mettere a disposizione di altre persone
le nostre conoscenze,
perché regolarmente,
a ridosso del weekend,
diversi amici ci chiedevano
suggerimenti per cosa fare.
E così, un po' per gioco,
un po' per scherzo,
abbiamo dato vita a questa pagina,
da cui poi è nato un libro,
"In montagna con i bambini",
edito dalla cooperativa "Most"
e scritto in Italiano e in Sloveno,
proprio per valorizzare
le lingue del territorio
perché, come sapete,
qua in Friuli Venezia Giulia
è presente anche la minoranza slovena.
Camminare è un'esperienza per tutti,
è un'esperienza anche in gruppo.
Ci siamo accorte
che è più facile far camminare
i bambini volentieri
quando si va assieme;
e quindi è importante,
per far amare loro la montagna
e far amare loro le passeggiate,
pensare innanzitutto a loro.
Quindi, accantonata l'idea
di raggiungere cime prestigiose,
perché ci sarà tempo,
e c'è stato tempo anche per quello,
l'importante è tarare
i percorsi su di loro.
Quindi, vinta la pigrizia,
ci si organizza.
Per prima cosa bisogna pensare al tempo,
perché è importante dare un'occhiata
ai siti del tempo -
qua in Regione fa scuola l'OSMER.
E poi, preparare lo zaino:
per i bambini, diciamo dai tre anni in su,
è veramente un'emozione
prepararsi da soli lo zaino.
Quindi, responsabilizziamoli:
si preparano lo zaino,
si mettono la loro borraccia,
il loro panino, il cappellino.
E poi noi, nello zaino grande,
portiamo tutto il resto:
quindi cibo, vestiti, cappellino,
crema solare, piuttosto che la mappa.
Ricordarsi sempre, anche,
il numero del Soccorso Alpino,
perché non si sa mai con i bambini;
e poi studiare un itinerario
che può essere attraente.
E che cosa piace ai bambini?
Gli animali, quindi le malghe,
che tra l'altro hanno. anche,
un punto d'appoggio
per qualunque evenienza.
Piacciono le cascate, piacciono i ponti,
e poi piacciono i percorsi,
magari un po' più -
dove c'è anche qualche roccietta,
dove ci si può arrampicare,
perché così si sentono grandi.
In tutto questo, però, va ricordato
che noi stiamo camminando
anche per entrare in contatto con loro.
Non ci sono cellulari, non ci sono tablet,
non c'è la televisione:
ci siamo noi, loro
e il silenzio magico del bosco.
Quale situazione migliore
per raccontarsi, per confidarsi,
per conoscere anche cose
che non immaginavamo dei nostri figli?
Il tempo di cammino
è anche un tempo di racconti:
quindi giochiamo insieme,
inventiamo storie,
"un pezzo io, un pezzo tu" .
E poi raccontiamo
le storie del territorio:
siamo in Carnia e parliamo degli sbilf;
siamo nelle Valli del Natisone
e parliamo delle crivapete,
e ancora: le agane, e i krampus.
La nostra montagna è ricchissima
di folletti e personaggi mitologici
che scatenano la fantasia dei bambini.
Quindi, diamo loro dei benefici fisici;
ma diamo loro, anche,
degli strumenti culturali
per conoscere meglio la loro terra.
Sta prendendo piede una teoria
secondo la quale, per i bambini
poco esposti alla natura,
e che quindi subiscono
un "deficit da natura",
ci possa essere una correlazione
con i disturbi dell'apprendimento:
questa [teoria è] ancora
in fase di studio,
però è una teoria che negli Stati Uniti
sta prendendo piede.
E sempre dagli Stati Uniti
arriva questa teoria del filosofo William,
ovvero che i bambini
che in età prescolare hanno sperimentato
situazioni di fascinazione,
quindi un'attenzione indiretta -
in un ambiente in cui
ci sono molti stimoli,
il bambino si lascia attrarre
da una specifica cosa,
come può essere la foglia che cade,
piuttosto che il torrente
che viene deviato da un masso.
Per questi bambini sarà più facile,
poi, in età scolare,
concentrarsi su uno specifico oggetto.
E di questo aveva parlato anni fa
anche Maria Montessori,
che è la nostra pedagogista
di bandiera, possiamo dire.
Proprio lei all'epoca aveva ricordato
come fosse necessario
far vivere ai bambini la natura -
ma pienamente, non solo dai libri -
e liberare i bambini
da tutte quelle sovrastrutture
che la società civilizzata ha creato
e che in realtà, per i bambini,
sono più ostacoli che piaceri.
Maria Montessori ricordava, anche,
che è importante che noi genitori,
noi educatori, noi zii,
non siamo iperprotettivi con loro,
perché i bambini hanno una forza innata.
E se sono nel loro ambiente,
e il loro ambiente è la natura -
questo permette loro di sviluppare
e di scatenare tutta la loro forza -
e poi, aggiungo io,
la sera dormono, a casa!
I bambini, se stanno in gruppo,
se stanno all'aria aperta,
sono felici:
lo abbiamo sperimentato
insieme a Francesca e Sara,
con cui ormai andiamo
a camminare regolarmente.
I bambini lo aspettano ormai
come un appuntamento fisso,
è un rituale per loro:
io penso, veramente,
che vincere la pigrizia, e fare lo sforzo,
sia il più bel dono che si possa fare
a chi vogliamo bene.
Grazie.
(Applausi)